Now, let's discuss
Stateful Inspection Firewall.
This is different from
Packet Filtering Firewall.
In a Stateful Inspection Firewall,
a packet is analyzed and
a decision is made based on
the context of other related packets.
Typically, this means the connection
this packet belongs to.
Therefor we need to record and
maintain information about connections.
And then decisions are made on each
packet based on the current state of
the connection and the context of
the packet within this connection.
More specifically as the packet
arrives at the firewall,
the firewall updates the information
about a connection accordingly and then
decides whether the packet is allowed
in the context of the connection.
For example, for
inbound packet, there is part of
an established email connection.
The firewall can check that the inbound
packet is a response to a previously
outbound packet.
In addition, the firewall can resemble
multiple packets of the connection and
inspect the connection data such
as the exact FTP commands or
which file the FTP is transmitting.
Or the firewall can actually look
into the page contents received from
a web server.